wopo has the answer shut down cop shows
now I kid you not this is this is their
solution to alleged police brutality
like many other industries entertainment
companies have issued statements of
support for the protests against racism
and police brutality now filling
America's streets but there's something
Hollywood can do to put its money where
its mouth is immediately halt production
of cop shows and movies and rethink the
stories have tales about policing in
America I just other reason I mentioned
this is to just point out the difference
between the fantasy of how the world is
working in the reality of it in the
fantasy version of the world cops have a
ton of power
cops are vicious they're slaughtering
people on the basis of their race
there's no way for us to stop them so we
got to muster all the power the people
and try to crack crack their oppressive
power structure in reality the opposite
is true in reality right now everybody
hates that hates the cops based on
nothing based on a completely fictional
narrative so much so that they're
actually trying to write the cops out of
popular culture even though cops or
getting sniped left and right during
these riots cops lives are not
considered to matter at all by the
popular culture cops go out they serve
are there some bad cops every once in a
while sure but the vast vast majority
are good people trying to help the
country out they get no respect they get
no support now even from the popular
culture some people are waking up to
this
[Music]
you
[Music]